so in addition in addition to you know
the zipcar being a certain challenge the
other challenge we faced was we you know
we did a casting call when we read our
actors but for the mother and father
were just offers based on a head shot at
a real and the actors that we originally
had playing the mother and father and
who are described in the sides as
driving a car this is a problem you only
face in New York neither of them had a
driver's license and neither of them had
ever driven a car and so when they
showed up we said wait a second you're
showing up to play the role of driver
and you never driven the vehicle and
that wasn't something that you thought
you might want to let us know so not
only did we have a car beat you know a
achill get taken out of commission
because it was in an accident but we
also had drivers who couldn't drive so
you know doing on day two was was a
necessity for numerous reasons was it
just a stationary did they did drive off
right yeah do they drive up and drive
haha so one point we're talking I'm
talking my producer you know can you
drive up that you know as a white guy
like wearing gloves or something and
then we'll cut to the close-up and we'll
swap in the actor playing the
african-american driver and then we'll
cut back to the wide and you'll drive
the car off and I'm thinking about like
oh gosh you know am I going to be in
after effects like trying to switch
somebody in like you know all the sort
of things that go wrong there but
thankfully we ended up just bringing in
an actor who could actually drive a car
and that was the best solutions
you